look they did it before and now the irs
is discriminating against conservatives
once again this time rejecting the
tax-exempt
request from a texas-based christian
group why because their biblical beliefs
sound too
quote republican in the rejection letter
christians engaged
the irs claims quote the bible teachings
are typically affiliated with republican
party and candidates
and therefore this disqualifies you from
exemption
joining me now is christian's engaged
president bonnie pounds
and her attorney lee patterson bunny i'd
love to start with you so the irs says
your beliefs are too republican
and not christian enough or at least not
distinguished enough from republican to
be seen as simply
christian what are your beliefs well we
simply are a christian ministry
non-partisan nonprofit
engaging christians around america that
it's time to pray for our elected
officials it's time to
pray for our city-state nation it's time
for us to vote and be civically engaged
and it's time for us to to follow god
into wherever we want to impact our
communities whether that's helping with
foster care kids
whether that's working with human
trafficking victims or
or helping with the preborn there's so
many issues in our nation
and christians engage is there to engage
the church and help the church awaken in
this hour
lee the irs says a 501c3 a nonprofit
cannot intervene in political campaigns
tell me what did
christians engage do to offend the irs
and what are some other examples of
organizations who have been allowed to
remain and keep their 501c3 status
well based on the irs's letter which
people can read for themselves
at first liberty dot org christians
engaged was
as you said quote bible teachings are
typically affiliated with the republican
party that's evidently the irs's
position
and that is contrary to both the irs's
own regulations as well as
constitutional protections for free
speech
and free religious exercise and there
are plenty of other civic organizations
across the country
who do the same thing that christians
engaged does and it's it's illegal and
unlawful
to discriminate against christians
engaged because of its biblical
viewpoint
okay so bonnie lee i appreciate you
bringing us in on this issue let's now
discuss
why this is happening in order to do so
let's talk to jason chaffetz who during
his time
on the house oversight committee
chairman investigated the irs's
targeting of conservative groups he's
now a fox news contributor
so jason i remember the story you
remember the story you were there during
the obama administration the irs went
after conservative groups
this isn't the exact same details but
does this sound
familiar to you it sounds
almost exactly the same there were some
400 organizations will
that applied for this 501 c 3 status
they were denied that
it was president obama who notoriously
said
there wasn't even a smidgen of
corruption at the irs
yet the american taxpayers had to pay
nearly these 400 organizations
pay them because they were wrongfully uh
designated as such and denied their
first amendment right to go out and do
this
so this case where they cite that the
vice chairman for instance
uh is a homeschooler uh she does
homeschooling
uh that one of the people involved in
the organization was a former political
candidate
they're trying to deny these people
their ability
to engage in their first amendment
rights under the 501c3 status
jason they're saying that christians
engaged is too involved in the political
process that they have political
operatives inside their organization
where do we draw the line so example
like where do you draw the line between
holding religious beliefs encouraging
religious beliefs and all of a sudden
oops now you veered into republican
party beliefs how do you draw that line
well the st the statute is very clear in
that of course it's the american way to
be involved in engaging in politics
on both sides of the aisle but they
continually go after conservatives and
republicans
planned parenthood has a version of a
501c3 do you see them going out there
and denying them
the ability of liberals to do this no
they don't they don't like that
republicans believe in the sanctity of
life
they don't believe they don't like that
they believe in a border wall that they
believe in a strong defense
that too closely parallels the
republican party platform and therefore
they want to deny these people these
god-fearing people
of having their right to participate
jason that's a great example i just
asked lee that question what are some
other
examples of 501c3s who also participate
at least closely to the political
process you bring up planned parenthood
so
let's get to the big question then why
jason we have talked as we should maybe
not enough but we have talked about the
institutions the bureaucracy the federal
government
like the doj or the fbi who seemingly
have taken political positions and
focused their their their bureaucracy
their organization's energy towards
political means and political ends
is the irs another political wing of the
democratic party
i'm afraid it is because there's no
consequence will
we've seen it at the department of
justice we've seen it at the
at the irs time and time again into much
to my exasperation
despite the fact that you have tygda
that the treasury inspector general for
tax administration
issuing these reports the ig at the
department of justice
continually highlighting how the
conservatives are targeted
it's a one-way street nobody gets
prosecuted
lois lerner is able to just resign take
her full full
compensation and nothing happens
really quickly only 30 seconds jason we
saw this as you and i both know and saw
at the time
under the obama administration do you
think we'll see more of this irs
targeting conservative organizations
going forward
yes they need to speak up and they need
to go out and they need to sue the irs
and take them for everything they're
worth
and the american people can't stand for
it but it has happened
more than 400 times that we have
documented
more than 400 documented times all right
jason chaffetz thank you for that
experience and that knowledge
good to see you tonight jason thank you
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else